you
so
what's up you guys i figured i'd show my
face and explain what's going on
you guys already know there's a server
queue
and it's jam-packed right now let me
show you my screen it is
uh oh there i am look at that and it's
kind of a mess right now
i waited and then got this error and
then
now i'm in the server queue so i just
wanted to
come in say what's up to you guys kind
of mope with you keep dropping the f's
and talk about what is gonna happen
today
um because there's a lot there is the
big
event that is going on today that is the
end of war zone as we know it
um but we can't get in let me
in i can't get in okay
hold on i gotta fix my picture in
picture look at that the little frame is
all goofed up
well i'd say i'd open the discussion to
you guys but the chat is moving
so fast right now thank you guys all for
being here you better not be in school i
don't want to hear that
don't tell me that stay in school
this is school is more important right
now look we're just waiting
focus on school please i don't like
seeing that
uh i'm gonna fix my frame here again
control
that'll do yeah look at that so this is
the screen and it hasn't moved
it says in the blue font underneath uh
battle pass it says season two
uh i'm sorry it says underneath season
two it says 20 minutes
ugh you hate to see it yes
rain in the f's oh my god i can't even
keep up there are so many f's i can't
read
if anyone's trying to say something
seriously
oh someone says cheater ridden game oh
roof
yeah that hasn't gone away um
but yeah today is the big event there's
a lot going on and i just wish we can
get to it because
this is it this is the transition from
season two to season three
the zombies have taken over dance we
have to see what's next
and unfortunately we can't
um so i might go on and off here just a
sec
because i mean you know i might just go
back
okay apparently when i do that
i mute myself so i'm gonna fix that but
all i said was thank you for all the f's
drop keep dropping f's for warzone
servers
for game spot for me for you
uh but please just stick around because
we got
we right now it says 20 minutes and i
you know i don't want to back out of
this so
i'm not going to i don't want to touch
anything um
but yeah here's what we know is gonna
happen
um
uh eric is advising me to to
chat with you guys eric taylor the voice
of god and
uh there is a lot gonna happen soon but
the thing is
there's only so much you know i think i
i don't wanna i don't wanna goof up
anything and
talk about any embargoed information
this is the big event that we are
waiting for it's the transition from
season two to season three
these zombies have taken over and
verdance is lost
so this is what's supposed to be
happening but it's not
and the timer unfortunately is not
updating
i'm pretty bummed so please stick with
bear with us
bear with um uh uh
the war zone servers keep dropping f's
ask me questions if you want
i but like i'm just seeing f's there's
no way i can read all this
appreciate you being here stay in school
i don't want to see those i'm in school
comments
oh my god i wonder i will be playing
with our very own aaron sampson
if everything gets uh up and running
here soon
i wonder if his servers are doing okay
or if he's uh
closer into the line than i am right now
this is
look at this cluster the splash screen
there's so much text on screen
i don't know what to do y'all i did what
i did just want to say what's up and
thank you for sticking around
this window won't be around you know
it's only going to be around for a few
hours so
we're going to stick it out and we got
to we got to play we got to play you
guys i'm ready
my controller is charged um got my sodie
but now we wait i don't even know
i don't even know i just wanted i wanted
to open the stream
with the whatever cinematic they're
going with but no we got
f's someone says god this is as bad as
a fortnight event more f's are coming in
i'm in school don't no don't
when does it start well i'm in the
server queue as you can see the screen
to
the thing to my right there's a jumble
of text 20 minutes
is the estimated thing but it's said
that for a while
alex yep diet soda pop that's it
all these f's thank you yes fs
apparently some people that we know are
playing
excuse me some people are playing but
the servers in game are lagging the
servers might have
servers might have crapped out guys this
is just the f stream
we should rename this the f stream um i
can't
really keep up with with chat so much
let's see here
okay i'm pausing the chat to see yeah
yeah so it's it's laggy for people who
are getting in it is laggy and for
people who are waiting outside like me
let me in
it's not it's not even happening nothing
is going on
just this screen and the server queue on
the bottom
move my joystick just to make sure that
uh we're not
you know i keep my place in line f is
for fun and we're missing out now that
is correct chad thank you
that is what's going on
i am corresponding with some dudes from
gamespot
yeah no i'm not going to back out of
this i as long as the
the bar on the bottom that says server
queue is moving
i'm not touching my controller except to
you know
make it not go to sleep
restart your game no way no way i just
said that
silent shadow says fat and stinky what's
up
bobby asks how was your day my main man
well it's like this
it's a lot of waiting i'm so happy
you're here all of you guys but this is
just
we're waiting in just like everyone else
i can't believe it i logged on early
i tested the stream the stream was good
and then it came down to this
so no luck
apparently i'm getting more
correspondence from eric tay and aaron
sampson
and they are telling me that the servers
are getting obviously hit hard but
i don't i don't know if it's looking
good for anyone right now this might
just be it for a while
got some people someone in the chat says
i'm in
quit playing quit playing
when can we download the patch yeah josh
yeah i'm sorry he just goes wow thanks
gamespot this is how it's
this is how it is man it was either this
or like the loop being the looping live
screen which i mean i could go back to
but
i just didn't want i did want to tell
you guys that
we're experiencing issues and this was
supposed to go up at 12 of course
but no luck yet
apparently uh activision is is posting a
quick blog article about what's going on
can't believe this continue to drop f's
while we wait i hope the timer this 20
minute timer has not moved
i think we're we're in for it friends
but thank you guys for sticking around i
mean
no i don't want to reconnect i don't
want to back out of this i'm really
nervous that free
that could i could either i could screw
me up and like
remove my place in the queue or might
fix things but i don't want to take that
risk we're already
already knee-deep in here waiting
yes keep dropping those f's thank you so
much
oh man hector in the chat says he got in
but he was immediately kicked out
that's what i'm afraid of jeremy in the
chat also says
i restarted and that didn't work thank
you for letting me know because i am
i was tempted to do that but now it's
not working the war zone update
is rolling out someone in chat asks but
it's not
it's not working these servers are
getting hit hard and
uh it's the first big thing that
happened to warzone in a while
um but let me see here i will check out
the the blog post
from uh
from call of duty let's see here
okay so i will in the meantime let's do
story time
about the the current blog post that
uh call of duty put up about the event
i don't think they've discussed the
issues going on but
we have a um the most recent blog post
kind of just talked about what's going
to happen
operation rapid sunder that's what we're
supposed to be in now over the past
year of our operation we had our
differences in disputes over the past
year of our operation
we had made errors and lost the
objectives
indeed over the past year of operation
there have been some friendly fire
incidents
this is just their blog post it's not me
just speaking to you guys
but this is the same task force that
infiltrated for dance day in day out
whether it be the brightest days
uh or the cover of night this is the
same task force that swayed the
mercenary shadow company
from our enemies and fellow opera
operators this is the same task force
that
overcame the nightmares of october 2020
which by the way i heard
is is canon because of the intel that
was provided anyway
and this is the task force that is that
has saved the world from evil
once before it's time to do it again to
the operators active in verdansk we must
honor the spirits of our fallen squad
mates and bring them justice no matter
what
uh host these parasites that have taken
over
your official order give them hell and
get out yup that's what's supposed to be
going on guys
the plague zones are supposed to be
popping up around the map
and they spread so there's no there's
like no escape but we're not seeing this
because of the server queue
is anyone in let me know in chat and
update me on your on your half over
there on your side
okay well there is a little more uh
mission parameters this is from call of
duty's blog post
uh arm assistance armisis central
command is
ordering an evacuation of all operators
and civilians from verdansk effective
immediately yes we know
per armistice code of conduct evacuation
efforts will be conducted as follows
once again if you're just joining this
is the blog post
we're in the server queue just waiting
for everything this briefing will be
updated as new information becomes
apparent
all updates will be visible to operators
as well as civilians
we will coordinate efforts using the
armistice pacific standard time okay
fancy way to say pacific standard time
it is expected that infiltration
or ex-filtration helicopters will arrive
across verdansk after 12 o'clock today
april 21st
due to the number of aircraft needed for
this evacuation and unusual wind
conditions across
custodia we have own
we only have an estimated time of
arrival for the first formation of
helicopters
but we expect evacuations to be finished
by 1400 hours
right this event was supposed to be a
two hour window and we're not
in yet we haven't moved in the server
queue
anyway i'll keep reading the blog post
here third due to containment protocol
communication efforts a system-wide
update
will need to be done across our network
this will require operators to manually
update their comms unit
for civilians their console starting at
2100 hours on april
i did that right before this server
queue so that's fine
given the above timeline timeline we
expect the operation to be successful
and comes to fully resume
by normal resume to normal
by 12 o'clock april 22nd
you have your orders now execute the
mission
i wish guys yes thank you all to those
who are here
dropping f's just reading the blog post
trend trying to get by trying to get
into the stream
which are the server queue here
uh apparently westy got in but it
crashed for him it's looking
bad you guys oh here we go activision
support did tweet
uh we are actively investigating an
issue with long wait times in the server
queue for warzone stay tuned for updates
ouch you know we we should have foreseen
this this is
probably the biggest thing that's
happened to warzone
this is the biggest thing that's
happened to warzone um
so a lot of people are waiting this is
this is tough
diet zodie here uh aaron sampson who i
will hopefully be
playing with just messaged us and said
that his timer has vanished uh-oh my
timer hasn't moved this is 20
minutes this whole time
nice someone in the chat said i'm in i
hope drop back in and let us know if
it's working for you or if you get
kicked
right now i'm not seeing anything but
this screen
so i don't think i want to back out
either someone in chat earlier said they
did back
out and it restarted and it didn't work
uh andrew i would advise you not to back
out
at this moment in time
ghetto connect says so i was playing i
exited now it says
and then he didn't fill in the blanks
there
your timer just disappeared too more
people's timers are disappearing this is
good news
mine is as you as you can see
wrestling castle says i'm playing guys
oh my god
more people yes more people are chiming
in i think we're getting a wave of
of of people entering from the queue
to the game
someone said i'm waiting for a game to
start
g that's correct it is never
straightforward with activision actually
excuse me normally it it is i think this
just this event is just
rattling their servers yeah they're
crashing
man let me check twitter for more
updates i haven't done that yet this is
this is a big day fellas ladies and
gents
okay checking out
my call of duty list here
oh yeah modern war modern war zone the
the news guy on
twitter he got in
man drifter could not get in he got
kicked out it looks like
people hey prestigious key looks like he
got in
not me this timer hasn't moved the
screen has not moved
thank you all for your f's love to see
it
love and hate to see it
let me know oh i'm getting more updates
from the chat
please tell me you're joking goofy
goobert's in this in the chat says um my
xbox literally started smoking
hector says it kicked me again
and some people in the chat are saying
that they're in the queue
just like me
snakeskin he says i just got in yes keep
us updated
yeah this is uh this is crazy guys
aside from that tweet no other updates
from activision or warzone call of duty
nothing like that just people flexing
that they got in
but also people on twitter are just sad
that they
got kicked out so that might happen i
might get in and then i'll just get
kicked out that may happen
personal persona yes this is an in-game
thing
and uh it's supposed to start at noon it
did but the servers are crashing and
it's not happening right now a lot of
people like me are in a server queue
waiting to get in and
i've been in here for a while i've been
in here for 20 minutes and that timer
has not
changed it says 20 minutes wayland says
just got in hell yeah keep us updated i
want to see if people are getting kicked
hopefully hopefully you guys can get
into
i will be playing soon hopefully with
aaron sampson from gamespot and uh
he's chatting with me he says uh
i might be on soon because we joined the
server queue around the same time
and it sounds like aaron is currently in
i wonder if it'll be um
you know like solo solos only remember
that like uh
know your history where it's kind of
that kind of event or like you know
i wonder if we can team up
no i'm not going to restart people
people in the chat prior have
said they restarted and nothing changed
che in the chat says or he asks if it
keeps crashing
i'm not even in yet people have been
reporting there that they are getting in
but it's
it's crashing f's everywhere i need i
need those f's
nothing guys hopefully this has been the
screens
this that you're looking at has been the
screen since we've started the stream
the stream so we're gonna i do want to
wait it out i think it's worth it to
keep my place in
the virtual line uh but aaron i don't
think will join me it looks like maybe
aaron
sampson did get in damn
so he's going to record it and break it
out for you guys to watch a little later
yeah this is pretty crappy loading
screens
they're so look at all this text wasn't
they weren't they weren't ready for this
this is the biggest thing that's
happened in war zone though you know
gadzooks
alejandra says restart the game it
worked for me
few people are saying they restarted and
they got them in
yeah zero hours 20 minutes 20 seconds
interesting
right yeah robert g says so much for
that 20 minute server cue that clock has
not moved
hmm
thank you guys for sticking around i'll
just discuss what's supposed to happen
today
the plague event operation rapid sunder
is the the limited mode where you drop
into verdansk
the plague zones keep expanding and they
don't stop expanding
fight the undead if you die to the end
kind of like what's been going on
if you die you turn into a zombie but
the end of her dance is going to happen
after that via something you know
people are saying restart i don't know
okay someone else on the chest said yeah
restarting didn't work at least on xbox
start the game it's working for me right
now
dino are you uh in a like a game or did
you see the cut scene
let me know what's going on
people are restarting on pc also i'm
getting some more intel from
eric tay the voice of god
and aaron sampson
for dance go boom zaza with the
black ops 3 reference
james says restart it it works guys i'm
freaking out i don't know
it's okay unknown says he sees the
cutscene
yeah some people are saying cap i think
anything's better than this but i just
don't want to you know lose my place
ah our very own aaron sampson who i was
going to be playing with he made it in
and he is cap in the footage ah
he he wasn't able to actually stream
but um we were supposed to play together
it stinks i'm happy for him though
okay aaron sampson said aaron sampson
from gamespot who i am corresponding
with right now says
he's in the lobby it just jumped from
the queue
to the lobby and he did not restart
so this is good news i think maybe you
know little by little batches of people
are
getting pushed in uh we're asking about
a
if there was a playlist update
it looks like these lobbies only have
100 players instead of like you know
what was it
so your game may crash if you start the
game
yeah they lowered the player account for
this i'm getting all this intel from
from our friends at gamespot
ebay
okay i will double check if um if
restarting
i mean hold on one sec guys
i will find out i guess let's double
check
because aaron sampson who i'm talking
with from gamespot
said he didn't restart dang it
hmm
thrilling isn't it
oh my god the chat is popping off you
guys are going so fast
okay people are connecting this is good
rl says we are telling you
wow now more people are saying restart
or don't restart
appreciate it guys i know you all just
want to help because right now it's just
me
in a picture-in-picture box and this
loading screen but we're going to see
here in a sec because um
waiting for maybe a little more
instructions here
okay
playlist update all right let's see what
happens guys
sheesh all right re-roll yeah i like
that i like that term
re-roll just re-rolling let's go
and there is a playlist update some
people are saying
reload trust all right all right guys
we'll see some
less people are saying don't restart and
a lot of people are saying restart i'm
in restart and then so
i know juan in the chat's like oof as
soon as i did that
yep
all right here we go let's just see what
happens
i did yep i restarted
big sip check it out guys
got my sweat rag freaking out y'all
nice some people are in
yeah some people can't even get in still
sometimes this fetching online profile
takes a while like when i'm just trying
to play regular warzone let me try to
back up again here yeah
fine
nightmare pb yep dude
this is crazy
night in the chat says i'm about to go
play apex man
i feel you on days like this this is
crazy
you see here
apparently this opens up with a 30
second cinematic
that supposed to kick off the event
someone said i'm just gonna go play my
wii
i did chat i did restart i don't know if
you just joined us i
maybe i'll restart again but now i'm
stuck on this screen
more people are getting in though that's
that's good to hear i'm happy for you
guys
and thanks for still being here i mean i
appreciate it
just got on more people are getting on
this is awesome yeah the servers are
definitely
busted
yeah should i just stream animal
crossing now guys
ah okay so it turns out there's a the
the cinematic
happens after you've finished the
mission
this whole thing isn't even supposed to
be long okay that happened
backed me up on its own there
i feel like i don't want to touch
anything guys but it looks like we're in
there it is top left destruction of
verdance okay
i'm just gonna go for it i don't i don't
know if it'll team me up with people
or if it's a solo event but here we are
you guys are crazy for sticking around
this long it has been
36 minutes i love each and every one of
you 1500 people watching now thank you
oh look okay put me with
oh put me with four people that's fine
good oh
oh put me okay all right here we go
fox in the chat oh all right let me back
out and be quiet
what the hell never mind they just they
just opened it up with that
and now it's back to a normal queue here
all right
let's go i won't be able to look at
chatter so so much but i appreciate you
guys being here i will check in
but uh we got in this is crazy i'm
finally in
i hope i don't get kicked out this is as
far as i've made it
some people haven't even made it this
far
no well the bruin has slow uh any
downsides
here we go
good luck you guys more and more people
are getting in all right this is great
this is great
looking around okay i didn't think
anything would happen in the
queue area the deployment
waiting area like this
hector green thank you
all these people please no spoilers
people are here to check it out who
can't
so chat do me a favor please no spoilers
i will read that though f for activision
yeah that's right
now we do this for real okay guys wish
me luck
gotta they teamed us up oh here we go
hear the music
here we go here we go
hear that sombra music this guy look at
everything is everything is
crossed out now
dude i can't even hear my call outs or
anything i hope that's not an error
or it's just like an artistic way to
make this really scary
the sound is so low
i didn't change any of the sound
settings
all right drop into storage town one
last time
hey look they give you guns eliminate
all targets
oh they gave me a jack 12 though
oh juggernaut armor this is nuts we
can't hear the music i know
you guys the audio dropped really low on
its own hang on one second
i don't want to die um while like
this is happening but i think you can
hear some right if it's if it's
incredibly low
no game audio damn it all right hang on
okay i'm gonna test out this uh jack 12.
let me know if you can hear
keep the comments coming if you can't
hear or if that was too quiet because i
want you guys to hear
they're just playing like you know
creepy uh zombies menu music
let me know let me know gotta keep up
with my team i gotta keep up with my
team
okay just lost him i wonder if he
responds
you guys here better good now good good
yes yes
there was juggernaut armor up there like
this is crazy
one of our dudes is a zombie oh no i
gotta reload this other gun
audio is good excellent okay good good
keep i like
appreciate those comments i already had
a gas mask we all do okay
found the gas mask here why did i ping
that then we all have one
cancel that um
this is pretty quiet nothing well you
just have to survive i guess
like normal
why is it just shotguns
[Applause]
no i like take this oh look
oh ninety percent waiting is fun knight
says in the chat yeah
waiting like this is fun at least
i'm gonna go get that what oh i'm gonna
go get that i already have that
they're dropping a lot of goodies for
this
i think people are responding back in
because um i swear i've killed the same
guy like twice already
i heard a zombie
confirmed
my team is so far away all right i'll
catch up with them
good luck people in the chat are saying
okay
good luck to you guys i hope hope it
works out we
we waited about a half an hour but it's
finally happening
oh i should have got into a car no the
zombies can emp
cars remember that it's happening though
i think i might hide you guys this is
crazy there's um
there are more more zombies
so the infection rate is creeping up
look at the plague zones
shoot yeah man
okay this is working out a little
differently than i thought
i just really need to survive and i hate
that i left my friends behind but i
thought like we could come back
okay okay let's go
no wonder they gave us just shotguns
yeah i need shotgun oh the smoke
okay let's go oh boy
[Applause]
watch the skies
no i'm down
no someone got an sg in the chat nice
good luck you guys there's still people
trying to get in i see you guys in the
chat
it took us forever it'll probably be a
while
but hang in there stay tuned to this if
you want to just see what's going on
i know you'll get a chance to play
eventually
they wouldn't be that scummy about it
they're going to let people
well we're all zombies now we gotta kill
people
to come back
can i kill their zombies
does it work like that whatever
we gotta go find regular humans to kill
helicopter or something oh shoot that's
shooting people i'm gonna get out of
here
oh it's rising guys i think we're gonna
get oh 95
okay look what's happening to the screen
okay we can't hurt each other we're
friends
oh but that guy has a gun let's get him
no dang it eliminate humans yeah this is
this is nice because it reminds me of
haunting of her dance but i want to see
what's gonna happen part two is tomorrow
that's so lame
it says check enemy soldier incoming
all right where the humans at
you need to end it
oh here we go guys
let's see what this means there's the
x-fil oh wow they they show it for
for everyone to see if you're a human
and you're still alive
did i just hear a gun
too many zombies we have to get out
look at this guys there's a juggernaut
that the zombies are not letting the
humans have
oh no he is there
god
we're still fighting off these damn
zombies
here we go guys look familiar it's too
late
all right i'll switch over
commander i regret to inform you that
their dansk has fallen
containment protocol has been initiated
wow it happened
there it is guys the nuke the fabled
nuke
finally happened or should i want to
quit
no what do i do yeah all right fine
there it is you guys
let's try it again let's try to actually
get the win and see what happens if if
it can happen
uh if if x fill is possible you don't
get any points for leveling up nothing
got the jack 12 upgrades and look at
that okay
so it looks like we get
a banner calling card destruction of her
dance
part one all right
people in the chat were saying part two
is tomorrow i'm gonna try again and see
if we can get the x fill
although it looks impossible
and you can't pick guns i don't even
think there was cash on the ground so
you can't get a loadout
but hey let's just try again i'm still
in the lobby let's do it
yeah there are part two part two um
chat was some chad was saying it's
tomorrow and i think
that's correct
yeah i would love to get an x-fill so
let's see if it's possible because my
god
chat is going off hope you guys are
getting in to the event
it part one i this was so short you guys
i'm pretty sure
yeah tomorrow part two three o'clock
pacific standard time that's what chad's
saying but let me uh let's see if this
had anything on the website
for part two
we're holding for deployment now's a
good time to warm up
okay well for those of you just joining
now
we finally got into the server let's try
to see if we can export
i didn't make it i made it kind of far i
killed like three guys but then the
zombies overrun everything
and it's bad those plague zones don't
stop spreading so
we all get like infected unless you're
that good
but yes as you saw confirmed for dansk
gets nuked wish i could play it again
but i don't have it
yes stadium the whole thing
burritos dad in the chat what's up
happy to see you again friend
just messing around until we get into a
game here another 10 seconds or so
yeah it took me a while for those of you
who are just joining it
we started the streets
30 minutes restart the game close the
game on ps5
open it back up and then it worked
ah joker adhd says that was lackluster
the event is fun um it's taken a lot
it's taking a long time to get here hey
that's a cool
niko skin i don't think i've seen that
before
no no it's not niko uh it's what's his
name i don't remember
all right get to a car i don't know
cars get emp but whatever i'll join you
survive look at that
all right it really
i mean it really helps to have a a good
team so we need a
i need to be a uh i need to be a good
team member this match
last time i wasn't i was just trying to
see what was going on
um but it was crazy
let's try to try to team up and be man
people are shooting their jack twelves
in the air
they are still
oh man this is a plague zone i'm getting
out of here
i'm right in the middle of this dumb
plague zone let's move out boys
actually that didn't hurt me which was
kind of cool
all right my heat's still if they're
still high up in the air
it's gonna be tough i'm separated from
them already
but i will try to make my way to them
now people are gonna run me over
there aren't enough cars friends
all right i'm gonna try to make it on
foot keep up with my team
but i parachuted too too late
we have to get out
[Music]
all right i'm getting closer to my team
here the juggernaut armor is dropping
it's gonna be a hot drop this is crazy
let's team up where's that guy going our
guy's driving away in the little atv
oh boy i think he's just driving around
to stay safe but
we will need a team yeah
should i go for that juggernaut armor
it's going to be hot no matter what i do
might as well
i just want to stick with my team that's
priority number one the more we can
stick together the better chance we have
fighting off
the growing number of undead
still can't get in dang it
i'm sorry i'm just reading the chat
there look at that that's one of those
cars oh it's a juggernaut
juggernaut no why did he try to face off
against the jug or not
[Applause]
there you go what am i doing yeah i'm
gonna die to this juggernaut
here we go
i heard him oh he's up there
cool they gave me an smg that's nice
all right stay with my friend we lost
one guy and he left he didn't even want
to be a zombie he just left
you're gonna take that you need that
i'll take it wait shoot
here i'll give you armor plates wait
come back
tactical ready marked okay sorry i
totally stole that from that guy
oh people are still waiting in the queue
man
i don't know how i got in guys i thought
i'd be sitting there for another half
hour
vehicle here you wanna get in the truck
it's not a bad idea it moves slow though
we can get emp
uh i wish i could talk to these guys but
i have my mic
off what's my backup oh yeah this
we're okay for now this is not look at
we're in a good spot because the
the plague zone isn't really hitting us
oh they're going for it or one guy is
all right
well it's me and purple here
who needs armor wait purple wait
come back move
oh he has some okay
where'd he go purple there you are okay
we gotta stick together friends
this is gonna get heavy and it's gonna
get heavy really fast i'll take that
no oh decoy i wonder if not zombies
i'll take it just in case i like it
better than the gas grenade
i can't believe i said that part two in
2022
nah man i think it's tomorrow
oh well vehicle
i like how fast the jack 12 is so i
think i might just keep
i do like this one though sheesh why not
wait where's my friend purple where are
you
take these while i'm here oh i'm full
okay the plague zone is starting to
spread behind us guys you can see
in this event you're supposed to kill
people and be the last humans
survive uh remaining
i'm kind of freaking out because one guy
died already it's gonna be hard for us
to
uh exfil successfully
you want fast guns and automatic
shotguns that's the best how did i get
into the queue i just waited man
that we were on stream the stream
started at 12 and until 12 30 we were
just
waiting and then at 12 30 we turned
off the game like you know powered it
down reset
and came back and it worked so good luck
we have one guy who's alive over there
a wholesome call of duty player i like
it that's that's kind of you to say
just want to have fun you know a lot of
people it's a tough day for a lot of
people trying to get into this
game so if you're watching i just want
to make it fun for you
this dude's got clips playing
yeah stick around because this event
we're going to play it for a while
um
sorry i'm reading i'm reading eric in
the chat there was a playlist
well you're in the right place if you
want to see what's going to happen
this guy's ass is all in my face move
oh no did you jump off no oh
where can you plant that cluster oh no
our purple jumped off
my friend purple it's time to get to the
exhale hopefully we can do it friends
get in the car get in the car
nobody zombies oh god get out
all right guys don't bring us in the
smoke driver i've got a cluster strike
on me
i think okay this guy i think is
going to play the smoke he's got a
technique here we're we're in the big
bertha
did he stop driving okay
i can throw it i can drive
will i be able to play part two tomorrow
i think that's what chad has been saying
you can't leave us out here yo what
don't bring us right into the
oh my god he's gonna run everyone over
we're getting empty
hey what i didn't die
i was still a human that's got to be
worth something i regret to inform you
that their dansk has fallen
containment protocol has been initiated
and scene that's what happens i was
still a human i'm really proud of that i
don't know if we
actually successfully x filled
but i was still alive so plus one for my
team shout out to purple
i didn't even read his gamer tag but we
did it man we
didn't die you can't x pill it's not
possible okay thank you chad
right i thought there'd be a special
cutscene if you could you know like the
last humans alive but no
um and that's fine because this mode is
still fun and it's only
for like another hour uh
for those of you just joining in let's
do it again nobody can ex fill nobody
can survive okay
thank you chad i appreciate that but we
lived we were still we didn't live but
we were still humans when it happened
we were in the x-fil zone but gigi for
staying alive thank you chad thank you
i don't think we made it in time it
looked like it we were like right
underneath the helicopter
jude in the chat asks how did we get in
the game
we waited friend we waited for a half an
hour
so why not let's just play it again oh
mr phoenix says disappointing af
mellow yellow's like what was everyone
expecting it's a nuke event simple
okay yeah for sure 2 p.m yeah we'll keep
going we'll keep doing this for those
who uh
who can't get to who can't play right
now um
we are here for you we are going to
stream this until
you know we can't know mo
check your gear and weapons planes are
making ready for deployment
wally says you've been in the queue
since noon that's when
i got in the queue at like 10 minutes
before noon
and then at like 12 30 we got on so i
think
you know what helped and it while yeah
restart i think you might need a
i closed you know the game file i closed
you know the application
uh came back i don't think there was a
playlist update
but i got in as soon as i restarted so
best of luck wally uh thank you for
sticking around i know
it's it might you know be hard to watch
if you're just trying to get in and this
is all you want to do but
appreciate you sticking around anyway
hopefully you can get in yourself
what happens if you exfil um you can't
it's like it's like a joke
uh carrie garcia in the chat you can't
you can
still be a human but you can't ex-fill
at least uh according to what chad's
saying according to what i've
experienced so far
but wally good luck he's about to
restart
yeah justin k yours your your waiting
queue says
20 more minutes right that's what
happened to me and it took a half an
hour and then i restarted the game
but uh it's it's tough right now it's
tough getting in
where should we go am i the squad leader
i am i hate when i'm the squad leader
um you know what i hate the airport but
it's in a good spot why don't we do it
tell me in the chat where your favorite
place to drop is or your least hated i
think that's the thing
uh ethan yeah we will be posting this as
a breakout just like gameplay with no
streaming stuff we'll post it later
um because it's a short event it'll be
it'll be a nice breakout
okay this turned into a
let's turn into a plague zone
well let's go here then get it secure
oh yeah they're firing down i'm gonna
make my way here i don't think i see
anyone yet
it helps if you have a team if you want
to like survive but as far as x-fil i'm
not sure if it's possible
but let me know in the chat i'll be
dropping into the ao primary objective
yeah when you die
you like dropping at the tv station okay
[Applause]
this is like the only gun that's
available
why can't we be friends
i didn't even hear that dude come in
that was scary
i don't know how i won that gunfight
also
every time you start you have to restart
the updates man
i don't know about that are you on xbox
it's that damn xbox
all right i gotta find some friends my
friends okay one guy's
approaching me and he is a zombie
he's a zombie
but zombies can't kill the other zombies
so this guy may have my back but
when it comes to a zombie he won't be
able to when it comes to another zombie
he won't be able to help me enemy car
enemy vehicle approaching
that was the move last time the three of
us got a car
kind of waited it out and we were still
humans by the time this was all over
this dude's jealous and he's beating me
up
whoa oh what that'd be fun
um shoot i think i'll give up the smg
hey how's it look oh how would you do
that
this is no friend of mine clearing my
pings
guys should i go for a juggernaut suit
it's really bold
i need a car if i wanted or other
juggernaut suits
man okay look it looks like my friend
over there is near one move to the
vehicle
if he's getting one then i'm gonna go
follow him i think he just died never
mind
this guy's literally breathing down my
neck
there's a real zombie out there
kinda okay
did my friend did my friend become a
juggernaut no
why am i running this way damn it
yeah you can't exfilt the scripted event
thank you i'm pretty sure that's
it i wanna i wanna just confirm that i
know what i mean
we were in the x-fil zone we were all
humans and we didn't get to x-fil it's
like a joke
but yeah you know scripted event it's
not a joke scripted event
where'd my zombie friend go he's gone
well it's ho-hum without my friends here
they're all zombies now
is that juggernaut available i'm gonna
go check it out if it's available that'd
be cool if i get some
juggernaut gameplay for you guys but i'm
out here like a sitting duck out in the
open look at someone died here like
this might not be this may be the end
for your boy
i don't think anyone's approached this
juggernaut suit over here
or let me back up okay that is an
active juggernaut i'm getting the hell
out of here what am i doing
it's been a while guys i haven't played
anything with juggernauts in a while so
i'm just gonna hide
try to live and try to like show you
what it looks like to get to the exhale
zone
get away from me
drop it into the area watch the skies
should i camp out
get away
okay let's go
hmm
i like how they give you a plate of
armor that's really nice
for every zombino you kill
i heard a zombie
and he's upstairs
get away from me
back i say back
oh he tried to emp me
respect oh man get away
he's gonna like super jump over here
watch while i can
there's a zombie on that roof
yeah i thought you were slick okay
that's pretty cool
i'm gonna get surrounded very soon so
the fun is almost over guys
get away from me
hey now
now there's a helicopter in the air
shooting i'm toast you guys
they got me
at least have rebirth what the f says
chat
i'm a zombie i'm a zombie that's okay
last time i wasn't a zombie so if you're
tuning in this time you get to see again
well you already know what it looks like
why is nikolai 664
talking twice on the left
is overrun all teams need to expel
immediately
there he goes super jump time
wait there's a guy over here he's trying
to
[Applause]
okay just as zombies i think they got
him
we're friends you can't hurt me
you can't hurt me oh i think that was
the gas
well whoop-dee-doo homeboy i'm back
yes average gamer says i am in too many
zombies good stuff man i hope you enjoy
thanks for being here stick around
simultaneously all right guys
i like that 360 okay so this is the
x-fil zone
this is where you know it all ends
people just keep bombing it with their
gas plates
this guy can't make the x-fill it's too
hot so they're going to nuke the place
out here i'm fighting off these damn
zombies
i wish she was like
all right this guy this guy's doomed he
was on a one-way trip
look at that i didn't notice that last
time okay so it blows up
scripted event you cannot ex-fill here's
what you get i'm gonna back out
containment protocol has been initiated
and we're back
let's do it again we've got you know
we've got time for those of you who are
trying to get in
appreciate you sticking around i know
it's it's hard on the servers right now
it took us a half hour to get in so we
want to
we want to use this thing we want to use
this event window for as long as we can
got xp for that almost got 10 000 xp
excellent
let's try again for those of you just
joining welcome
thank you so much you do get a calling
card yeah i got it already uh and i will
show it to you right now for those of
you who are just joining in
once you finish this event for the first
time you get a calling card
and this is nice because i get to clear
out that green square that i hate so
much there it is
look i'll equip it containment
protocol adam stewart in the chat says
finally got in
richard pagan hey what's going on man
when is part two
tomorrow i think because this thing was
only like
two hours like this is nothing it better
be tomorrow
yeah all right well that's the uh
calling card
let me clear this real quick because i
hate when those are there
and then let's try it again let's do it
yep very dance go boom confirmed finally
happened remember when there were rumors
of that like
uh actually let me back out here
remember there were rumors of that um
um in like season two this whole thing
is getting nuked
i'm trying to i'm trying to invite aaron
here um
he's in he's already playing he's in a
not joinable game maybe next match
destruction of verdansk baby
it happened
it happened can't believe it can't
breathe
so when's the next part
chat was saying tomorrow tomorrow sounds
likely because this was
you know this was a big deal we can't
just have this event repeat for like a
week you know that would be silly they
said this was a two-hour thing so
my guess yeah sometime tomorrow but
after this two hour ender
this two hour window ends i do want to
see if there will be
you know if it's just back to regular
verdance which would be stupid i don't
know
i don't know i wonder what's gonna
happen between after this
and like tomorrow when
something else happens
grab some target practice while you can
we're deploying soon
all righty back at it again just get a
good look in everyone for dance as we
know it
smell the air hate on the brown and
green
motif one last time because it got nuked
uh lucas these were like uh estimates
and guesses like
uh about times and stuff i i'm actually
curious to see what they do right after
this event
uh tomorrow just seems like likely like
if this is a multi-part thing they call
this part
part one so i'm assuming part two is
soon like we got a big ass you know
software update
so i'm sure it's it's already in the
game files
at least i assume so
ah i've heard dance look at this what do
i have here
no what one lesson all right enough
now we do this for real uh gus no we
can't win this it's like a you know a
scripted thing
uh you can you can try to ex-fill
there's an x-fil site
and there's like a helicopter waiting to
ex-fill the helicopter blows
up and the verdansk gets nuked so you're
about to see that happen right here
hopefully you can get in and play
yourself
because this is a limited time thing
stop being nerdy just play relax relax
you go play you watch me you stick
around for the nerdy
but here's how it's going down all right
everything is con
as uh uh what's the word contaminated
try to survive you don't survive you
turn to a zombie
any trick into getting in no i waited in
the server for
20 minutes and then uh
restarted the game i keep doing this i'm
not going into this containment zone
this is exactly what happened last time
it's hard i can't i can't uh
you know do the chat and play at the
same time i'm terrible at it
why they
[Applause]
the queue took me it it said 20 minutes
but the timer didn't move
so like it could take any it can take
forever
i'm so far
we all become zombies anyway but you
can't survive and you can still
end this event as a human i did
one time but um
it ends no matter what what is this
music
why do i have this oh
it's 115. okay
wrong button i meant to turn off the
music
do i have a shot at the juggernaut
[Music]
all my friends are all over the map this
is nuts
i mean it kind of helps if you play as a
team but it's not necessary because
no matter what there's one fate there's
the fate of her dance and it happens no
matter what
[Music]
so you can survive or be a zombie
to see it and you'll still see it
riding around the block oh man they
really nerfed
the turning radius on these things i
hate driving those 18
am i being chased
there we go
to the tunnel on the damn yeah the x-fil
the final ex-fill sight
is there's a crash ball the final x-fil
sight is at the damn i will show you
guys
when things get closer because all these
containment contagion zones
are spreading like crazy and it doesn't
stop spreading soon that will be that
red
area will be the whole map
one guy is a zombie on my team
no way can i do it they're blocking it
out of the way they're blocking the
juggernaut suit
man there's another human enemy dropping
into the air
i should have killed him but he's going
for the juggernaut suit if he gets it
i'm going away
just getting a good look at her dance
while we can guys
i'm not really doing much now you can
kill people get points and go respond
as a zombie um
but we're here for the main event what
happens afterwards
all right it looks like in the chat it's
getting easier to
um get into a lobby so you can play
yourself
wow that's great that's great this
morning it was a mess we waited for a
half an hour
oh i crashed into this stupid sign so
what's the main objective
uh it's funny it's it tells you at the
beginning when you're
when you're dropping it against the only
objective is to survive
get away from me this guy ruined my car
okay let's go okay
get away
oh he's smoking me out oh well you'll
get to see what it looks like to turn
into a zombie
because i didn't reload my gun like a
noob
lucas says hey bro do you know if there
will be any more parts to this
at the moment says part one i'm assuming
you know like
you can't just have a part one and leave
us all hanging we have to know what
happens next
um as to when i'm guessing
like tomorrow or maybe jack can tell you
but
if anything has come out of history
it would make sense that it would be
very soon they can't leave us hanging
with with no verdance you know every
dance is nuked like whatever he wants to
do
something's gotta happen
is that my friend who's breathing down
my neck my friend
this is not the xvil zone oh they're
trying to kill the juggernaut
and they did look at that get away from
that
all right well let's see here see look
at the the zone is
shrinking and it ends at the dam so
let's just go to the dam
michelle in the chat says there is no
escape run while you
and i accidentally hid that message my
bad i meant to show it off
all right more people in the chat are
getting in yeah
um i don't know how much longer we have
to wait
but i do know that this event that we're
looking at right here ends at two
o'clock pacific
pacific standard time
someone is oh that's me i was like who
was following me that's just my own
zombie voice
freaking out okay
let's see yeah we're getting closer to
the dam
this is the only x-fil zone look at this
helicopter
fighting for his in life
oh my friends are zombies and one guy
left brandon hernandez what up
good to see you old friend
see this is the x-fil zone
[Music]
the shadow doesn't cover the ass that's
pretty funny
containment has failed and you need to
end it
part two is in 35 minutes sheesh
that's what someone in chat
hey
who's actually shooting me with a weapon
who's got who's still alive
oh it was probably that thing
or maybe the jug anyway
we just got the call out he said get to
the ex-fill site which is
this which is the damn there's too many
zombies
we have to get out
[Applause]
what if we can no i'm too short
let me get on top of the damn and try to
hop in that helicopter
oh no the helicopter shooting me
bad idea we're at the x-fil site and
it's hot
not sure why i pinged it
you can't leave us out here we're still
fighting off these damn
zombies how high can i jump i can
finally go up damn
nope that guy did he's too late
look at this guy can't exvil the
helicopter blew up
enemy soldier we're about to get nuked
watch
commander i regret to inform you that
their dansk has fallen
containment protocol has been initiated
wrong one there we go so that's what
happens
scripted event no matter what you do the
x fill site is too hot
where dansk is lost and it gets nuked
don't want to quit yeah for now
okay this time i'm going to invite
gamespot's very own
aaron sampson and for those of you who
are just watching thanks for for tuning
in
this is uh that calling card that i had
just there you get that
when you uh when you complete
this little limited time mode it's a
short one but
um you know it's gonna kick off season
three in a really big way because
there's more coming
this is not it
jacob in the chat says try restarting if
you're having trouble getting in yeah
that's
that's what worked for me so i give you
that advice yep ronan's go boom
it got nuked let me invite aaron here
not joinable oh god oh you know what
um huh
oh he's watching the cut scene right now
he says okay
not enjoyable i wonder if i have um
yeah look it doesn't appear that i'm
online let me turn that on
profile online let me see if that works
so we can join up with aaron sampson
no luck it's not letting me join him
um give it another minute here see
what's up with chat and see if aaron
can join us
hope part two entire new map i hope part
two in 30 minutes yep two o'clock
more people are saying that when's the
live event start
thomas tomas thank you
can't can i join him still no
so strange
yep i have crossblade turned on as far
as i know yep it is enabled
no luck i think i might just go again um
because i can't join aaron i'm talking
to aaron offline and i can't
it's not working he's there not joinable
can't join
so we're gonna go and try this again
show you guys
what it looks like for verdansk to get
nuked
squad filled all right i'm just gonna do
it again
sorry aaron i don't think it's gonna
work out it says you're in an unjoinable
lobby
and aaron's not even seeing me online so
it's goofing up
yeah he says oh well we tried
welcome to those of you who are joining
this is
the end of verdansk part one
let's see what's gonna happen i mean for
those of you who have been here you
already know but
for those of you who are just joining us
this is a two hour window
limited event for part one
where zombies are fully infecting
verdansk and it's time to say bye bye
open party we're holding for deployment
now's a good time
does not work i tried so many times i
was even a human one time
like i didn't turn into a zombie and the
x-file didn't work because the
helicopter
blows up it's all like a big dramatic
cinematic event
what is this gun oh
all right so let's we're gonna drive
around in the lobby and wait
enjoy ever dance while we can look at
the beautiful icy water
the dam up ahead
yeah gregory this isn't something like
that's meant to be repeated over and
over but you know for stream
people are coming and going and trying
to see what's going on so
i'm gonna keep replaying this until we
can't no more i think
two o'clock it's supposed to end at two
and we'll see what happens next but yeah
if you played this
event once like you know what happens
for dance
you know what's up and uh you don't have
to keep your feet you don't have to keep
playing it
look at this here we are damn
you're done warming up stand by for
deployment to the war zone
nope it is not a it is not possible
to escape in the helicopter i'll show
you
not right away it happens like the
plague zones keep spreading
and all of verdansk is like red you know
like
all of it is covered in gas by the end
of the match
and the x fill zone is damn and it gets
overrun
so you can't do it yes gameplay says i
got it look at see my only mission
survive i'm the party leader
you know what let's um
storage town where haven't we been i'm
just gonna drop into
boneyard
for one last time man for some people
it's still not working
the servers were having issues all
morning guys i hope
i hope this is enough like just watching
i hope it's enough but i hope you can
get in
too i would love for you guys to get in
and see this for yourself let's get it
done
they are still fighting give them
a chance
there are juggernauts but they're
impossible
nothing but shotguns one smg and like
armor that's it
that's all they give you and you you
come you you drop with a jack 12
all the time what am i doing what am i
doing okay i'm gonna get that car
look around before the zones start to
spread all of the old zones have spread
or now they're here they're back and
they will continue to slowly spread
watch this
all of them spread and they don't stop
yo has anyone jumped on the train yet
maybe we can pick up some stuff
there isn't much there's like i said
there's only yeah someone's been here
there's only shotguns
and uh one smg
i was looking for armor but you have
just too many zombies we have to get out
we
all right it's like 500 meters away but
i'm going to try to get this one
see i haven't got that's one thing i
haven't done yet is get a generous
that would be cool and that'd be really
helpful but it's going to be a hot
zone look someone my friend died over
there or my teammate
i don't know if i should be doing this
but why not
when you die you respond and just come
back as a zombie so it doesn't end like
normal
you know br well it's like on the roof
or something
stupid card oh my friends are
dying
oh hopefully no one's got it yet it's
like all this stuff actually
here we go
ah someone's been here though look it
might have been a zombie
yeah i hear a zombie ah that someone got
the juggernaut suit
rats there's a dude over here what the
hell
okay i saw stitch i think he ran out oh
he's on top
dealing with actual humans come on
someone's here i hear him rock walking
around i was gonna say like running
around
well someone escaped with the juggernaut
suit so i have no business here but
i haven't really visited this place in a
while
there's someone over here a human
are all my friends yeah look i'm about
to hit the smoke you guys i think i'm
gonna get out of here while i can
i'm driving three-point turns i don't
have time for this
you get a gas mask let me see if i can
catch up with my friends they're all
over here i'm like
get away from me watch the skies
fortunately there's no long-range
weapons
all my friends are zombies maybe i
shouldn't go over there because that's
apparently where all the smoke is at
these zombies can emp you also just like
before look at that
thanks a lot
jerks oh that's a friend he helped me
out
perks of being a zombie yeah
wait is it still is my engine still
failed
get away from me man i blew it
where were you on that one
okay so this is what happens obviously
when you die
you try to kill the remaining humans
and uh and try to prevent them from
ex-filling at the dam
i'm running around like i can lose so
i'm just i don't need to be doing that
so i'm gonna go
towards the dam yeah
oh she as a zombie you can drive the car
that was a pathetic jump i was too close
to that rock
let me know how it's going in chat guys
are you guys finally getting in
chad is saying at least there aren't any
cheaters here yeah that'd be really
pointle
that'd be really low for cheaters to
spam these lobbies like
enough
i love that
get away there's the x-fil zone if
you're
a human and not a zombie this is where
you're supposed to drop it into the area
quit hitting me
that thing can shoot you so i'm not
going to stay too close
see this poor helicopter was just trying
to explain it keeps getting pushed back
i wonder how many humans are left i wish
they would overrun
all teams
[Applause]
okay
there we go look at look at that big
arrow those arrows of hope
like x fill here x fill here it's okay
it's not
well i'm a okay so it's okay oh wait the
juggernaut
is he cornered up here it's about to be
over for this dude where is he where's
the upstairs
roof
well he's not on the roof roof he's just
cornered in here but he's about to get
smoked out look at this
the helicopter blew up
feast your eyes
commander i regret to inform you that
beardansk has fallen
containment protocol has been initiated
f's in the chat for verdansk it got
nuked again this is like the fourth time
this is
this is great two o'clock though is
coming up soon
hopefully something will happen that's
the end of this part one event
so stick around but for those of you who
are just joining hey what's up
this is part one of the nuke event it's
happening
it's actually happening you cannot
ex-fill
it makes it look like you can but you
can't
i was a human i got to the x-fil zone
with my whole team
earlier today there's no x-fil the
helicopter the
the x-fil helicopter blows up it's a
scripted event you know like it's
there's no way out verdansk is doomed so
let's do it again
thank you kevin for all the f's all of
you guys f for verdansk thank you f
thread
thank you
let me back up here because someone in
the chat said something crazy
no
great two o'clock we're looking to see
what happens after this ends
so stick around stick around
reloading the app isn't working for q
fix any other suggestions i'm
sorry k that's that's what i did i
waited in the queue for a half an hour
live and then and then we restarted we
closed the app
and opened it back up and it worked
no point in fighting as a human because
you'll still lose yeah i was a human one
time and it ended and uh
we lost no one wins in verdansk today
baby
look at that rose skin i never unlocked
it i think it was season
five at the end and i got like more than
halfway through the battle pass but
i didn't i didn't make it all the way
through
okay for those of you just joining
here's another intro this is what's
going on with verdance today
it is being overthrown by zombies it's
finally happening
and you're here to see it all
if you die in this particular type of
war zone
uh you turn into a zombie no matter if a
human kills you or not
so get in get in all these get in all
these looks
one last time good old quarry it was
better than
enemy solar
i never land here but
take it in while you can look at this
before it's gone forever
okay 20 seconds i'm going to run around
do something yeah
enemy soldier ain't coming
no one uses this gun i mean that's
usually this one right here
it's usually a bad sign that it sucks
but it's so powerful it's just jumpy
but it's not even that jumpy hold on let
me see here what's the truth
you're going to the war zone no one no
one ever uses this gun i think the the
time to kill is too slow for war zone
you know it's kind of a
chugs as a lmg all of them do except for
the bruin
what happens after this we're waiting
for two o'clock mike mike in the chat
is dropping all the deets i hope i can't
say whether or not those are all correct
but i mean
you know keeps dropping it like it is
verdansk is kaboom correct
listen
that's our only mission ladies and germs
survive
i'm just gonna drop somewhere forget it
it's it's not so the emphasis is not
really team based i mean you can
go around killing zombies and get that
xp but your only
mission for reals is to survive marking
rally point let's go to um
guy what was this modern warfare 2 map
called god i forgot
wow tripping i love this map too
anyway survive eliminate all targets in
the i o
it helps to have a car only so far
because you can get emp
but i'll take it anyway it's fun
actually let me find some armor first i
need to loot a little bit
i'll try to stay human for as long as i
can but for reals guys there's
honestly not that big of a benefit
because um
you can't ex-fill it's part of the fun
and make it look like you can too it's
like oh there's the helicopter and it's
like
nah son all right well i got the armor
let me see if i go round up my team i'll
go oh i'll take the suv instead over
here
they only give you shotguns two or three
of them there's like
the hauser or the howard what's it
called uh this
this smg and the jack 12. ugh
zombie put them
he probably knows oh
he got in okay that guy has a mixed team
of zombies
and
no point in doing this honestly but well
you know i'll leave him alone
he's just trying to have fun like we are
i'm sorry i don't have the event times
for the uk all i know is that it's going
on
right now and i think it might be
worldwide
[Applause]
in this mode also there are juggernaut
drops but they're very hot
and i would say not worth pursuing i'll
drive
you ready when you finish the game will
there be a part two
we're thinking the part two comes at two
o'clock because that's when this event
ends
so stick around we got another jeez
we got another 15 minutes you jerk
[Applause]
right around the block let's get back in
it okay
i'll drive you ready so you'll lose no
matter what yeah mellow yellow you got
it i think you're helping
explain yeah it's scripted right
look at that look at that it's spreading
the map the plague zone from before
they're all spreading
slowly look at this wait what the heck
it stopped maybe this one
that's so strange earlier when i showed
that you know they spread
there's the x-file helicopter i'm
pointing like you guys can see but it's
over there the x-file helicopter
um so one of my friends is a zombie and
the other guy is not i'm gonna go see
what he's up to
he is the green player where the hell is
he he's all the way over there
someone died here
why is this event in parts good question
maybe i mean
the nuking verdance is a big deal so i'm
sure they wanted players to
uh take a breath you know kind of
realize what happened and then uh
i assume they're just gonna go right
into part two i don't think it was any
sort of technical limitation
although the servers have been living
straight
this morning but we got in um
you know i did anyway uh some people in
the chat i think are still trying
so good luck to you all get away
ruin my car i'm ready to fight him oh he
blew up my car
oh this guy better move
hey does he want to be friends or is he
like
you know teabagging me from 30 meters
away
i think he wants to be friends i mean
i'll be as friendly as i can but he's
trying to i'm going to get smoked out
here
come on he's probably gonna beat me up
he's
that's no friend of mine just kidding i
hope so i like when i make war zone
friends um
and we do the little you know duck duck
thing that's only happening
once there's no
ah someone else hit me
there don't be okay that is definitely
my friend we are friends confirmed
i'm walking right into a plague zone oh
no
no don't kill him don't kill him don't
kill him don't kill the guy he's a good
guy
no i try to talk into the mic like an
idiot
you get to see what it looks like to be
a zombie now you're familiar with this
uh and you get to see what it looks like
x-fil zone coming up soon
that's cool that i made a friend though
even though i shouldn't have done that
my heart is too big part two in 10
minutes maybe
which is perfect maybe i think there's a
timer on the left for five minutes
okay that's when the x fill happens no
matter what
belly yellow quit playing i am a zombie
now we are
we were friends in life and after life
bro
there's the xville
well there's the helicopter eventually
the x-fil zone closes in the damn area
but if you get too close to this thing
it'll shoot you scrapyard that's what it
was thank you
look these zombies are not letting
humans pick up the juggernaut boxes
this one is still here oh the helicopter
though too close too close
that helicopter can and will shoot you
i'm getting farther away
just me and the homies being zombies
let's find some humans we can kill some
humans still
hmm
that's correct you can i'll show you you
know we're going to the x-fil zone now
this is the final x-fil zone right here
that i'm pointing at
yeah man jesus
there's the x-fil zone that's the
helicopter trying to
make the escape but in three minutes as
you can see on the timer on the left
over there
um you'll see what happens
if you don't already know
how'd that not kill me a and b what was
trying to kill me
was it the helicopter
human and you're surviving you know they
take to go here
you cannot exfoliate it doesn't work
make it look like you can you get so
close and then
you'll see you'll see i mean you know
what happens but you'll get to see
look at this you can't leave us out here
we're still fighting off these damn
zombies
it is too late for xfil
those you're right out of there
enjoy check this out
commander i regret to inform you that
verdansk has fallen
containment protocol has been initiated
there it is that's what happens to
verdansk
f's in the chat please if you please
now we uh i think we have time i might
just
hang out in the lobby because in five
minutes this event is over
and that was part one we're gonna see if
part two kicks off right away
we're guessing two o'clock i think uh i
think it is all but confirmed
but here let me show you what you get
for those of you just joining in welcome
this is the end of verdansk as we know
it and for doing this event this event
ends at two o'clock
and if you're able to get in and you
know
see it happen you get this calling card
yep that's it um
and you know it's a big history making
event
for a war zone so hopefully to see what
happens next i wonder
you know if uh um part two will start
right at two o'clock
i kind of want to start another match
but i don't maybe i'll
huh what do you guys think in the chat
let me know should i just hang out here
chat with you guys for another five
minutes or get another game going and
like back out what do you think
part two is up now someone says part two
is up now pops
is spamming the chat saying part two is
up now
you have some good weapons or layouts
you might share um
that's that's kind of you to ask i'm not
it sounds silly coming from the guys
streaming call of duty but
i uh i'm not like the greatest war zone
player i like multiplayer i mean my
classes are
a mix of totally meta guns like you know
what's hot right now like ffar and the
um the mac 10 as
a overkill weapon but i usually try to
play
off meta because it's i think it's
funner like check out my favorite class
for
for actual war zone you guys are going
to laugh at me but it's this
um the fennec the fennec cannot be beat
up close i swear to god
although the mac 10 is probably better
at this point
the fennec is was my baby i got it gold
like
the day of i was like oh my god i love
this gun and it's not supposed to be
that good i think you should give it a
shot
but yeah i wouldn't other than that i
wouldn't give i wouldn't take
my warzone advice that seriously because
i'm not the best warzone player i like
to play but
yeah i've only won like a handful of
times you know
yeah the servers and i'm reading chat
here katie says uh the servers are all
messed up today yeah
part two is up now pops you better quit
playing then
when is regular coming back regularly
the regular map
i don't know man it got nuked the map is
nuked for dance is lost we're gonna see
what happens
can't read that comment there bank sorry
about that when is this done two o'clock
that's why i'm kind of stalling here
guys
in another three minutes we're gonna see
uh
because this is part one the event you
just watched me play over and over
it's part one part two supposed to be up
very soon uh bank i cannot read that
comment either
yeah i can't wait for part two either um
thank you guys for being here um
and just hanging out with me just
another few minutes i'm not sure if i
should like uh
this if the servers are still kind of
goofing up maybe i should back out and
try to get in like to the server queue
of part two
i might have i might have shot myself in
the foot but let me just see what
happens
no looks like the servers are okay as
like before i couldn't even get past
this screen um when does the new map
start
we're looking for two o'clock so i'm
gonna try to
i'm gonna stand back maybe wait for a
playlist update
and see what's up drink my my diet soda
here
we got some hype in the chat zine says
i'm excited a
f thanks for the content thank you guys
for sticking around this is kind of a
weird
in between zone in another minute here
we will hopefully see
what's going on um oh man
got some got some cod haters for sure i
see um there's some comments that are
like automatically hidden
if you guys say the f word and stuff
it's going to get automatically hidden i
don't even do it it does it on its own
twitter says rebirth island is next
that's a good idea let me check twitter
for some official
sources because the truth is guys i saw
or we we we went to uh
uh aaron sampson who works at gamespot
went to
a event that call of duty hosted
he got all the intel you know all the
stuff is was embargoed and we couldn't
talk about it forever and now that today
is the day
i can talk about some stuff but more
stuff is coming and we're gonna have to
stick around to figure it out but
for now i want to see what the official
sources are saying
call of duty on twitter
what do you guys follow on uh on twitter
and youtube for call of duty stuff i
like
i like drifter uh prestigious key
exclusive ace those are like the three
main guys i always go to
and on twitter it's a whole different
story people love to leave stuff on
twitter you know
let me know we're gonna see here let me
try this again it is officially two
o'clock i'm going to click and play
see if anything changed not yet
just ended our just checking out twitter
again for more official stuff
up here we go activision of activision
support made an update about
the trouble connecting to the servers
okay
okay i'm away from twitter i'm gonna
check the chat what's going on you guys
now there's another server queue okay
let me back up here try again
this is where i was stuck for a half
hour because um
you know um this was where the server
queue was so hopefully
maybe i should have done this sooner but
this is how it's gonna be for a little
bit i'm hoping look at that checking for
an update good good
kevin in the chat says i don't have it
either yeah hopefully it's just
it's just kicking off now you know what
i'm saying
you just restarted you know what that
helped last time let me back out
you just back oh no no no look at that
idiot me the 80 not you
it was checking for update means it is
updating that's a stupid way to
phrase that restart that's what i was
about to do
but until i saw that warning pop up i'll
i'll give it a second
see what's up hopefully part two is just
ready to roll and smoother
because they were dealing with a lot of
maintenance issues today
restart your game it worked last time i
want to see
the game kicked me just reading chat
i started the update among us
you know why do you guys keep saying do
you guys still play that game or just
enjoy the memes
among us you don't restart the fbi is in
the chat saying don't restart
so
one says f this i'm gonna go play
fortnite all right
we're waiting for part two for those of
you just joining that's what's going on
now i appreciate you
sticking around all seventeen hundred of
y'all
thank you this is great um
hopefully soon we'll just be able to
play part two
you saw enough of part one where dance
got nuked
let's see what happens next
no no um evac you are not late i mean
you're late for part one part one ended
and i will
update you zombies you know we all knew
it was coming zombies have fully
infected verdance the limited time mode
was
trying to escape verdansk guess what you
couldn't
there was an x-fil helicopter it blew up
and then they nuked verdance and we saw
a cut scene
we will be posting that if we haven't
already on gamespot's
youtube page so if you want to see that
little cut scene and some gameplay i
think it'll be up soon
but it just happened so if it's not
there give it a moment we're trying to
figure out
we're in the server queue hopefully for
part two of that event so
verdance got nuked
okay i'm just gonna back out hold on
i've been disconnected i'm offline
look at that all right let me now now i
will back
up close the what the close the game
and then open it back up
trippy you better be playing with that
comment that's probably just a joke
do i like diet dr pepper for the fifth
time
no i like regular but i always try to go
look i had today uh i like diet
coke it's a good way to just not oh look
the server queue
okay good good good uh yeah diet coke
don't drink your calories
stupid coming from a big guy but you
know whatever what are you gonna do
among us gets nuked
no
man y'all are heated there are these
these comments that are being
automatically
blocked with like f words up and down
so what happened okay for those of you
just joining i'm probably gonna say that
a lot but
people are coming in and out of this
stream thank you for being here
verdansk got nuked there was a limited
time event that
ended at two o'clock part one ended at
two o'clock
zombies took over verdance got nuked no
one could ex-fill
they made it look like you could you
were almost there and then
nah it got nuked it is gone we're gonna
see what happens next yes
drop your f's because verdansk is toast
it is vaporized
um and we're in the server queue now for
hopefully for part two this looks like
something is happening let's see what's
up
people are saying that um um
what's his name modern warzone on
twitter the the homie the leaker guy
and the news guy he's saying it's
rebirth island
like that's what's supposed to be next i
mean it makes sense because verdansk is
nuked and they're gonna force us to play
on rebirth
uh sound that sounds correct that sounds
cool
mellow yellow says frick not a pie says
modern well you guys are going bananas
down there
thank you for all the f's for f for dan
skip
yeah this is what happened when we
started the stream thank you guys for
those who have been here the whole time
like whoa thanks but this is what
happened
when we started the stream you can
barely see
but in the blue writing it says there's
a 20 minute wait
um and so we'll wait for you know we'll
wait a little bit
but eventually we restarted because we
became
30 minutes just sitting here so we
started
and we did get in after some
troubleshooting
server got nuke too oh my god that's so
funny oh yeah you're welcome for those
who were just dropping in uh yeah
verdansk is gone
i hope you know i hope uh
you don't miss it because it's nuked
um let me see here i'm gonna check with
uh the production crew behind the scenes
okay uh looks like aaron sampson our
very own aaron sampson from gamespot got
into this but then got like kicked out
right away the screen
went gray like
[Music]
we're all just kind of waiting here okay
chad is also in the queue
thank you guys for being here and take a
sip of water one second
stay hydrated folks
there we go so does the upgrade through
does the update go through today yeah it
should be it should be
soon part one already happened
and we were left with you know questions
what's gonna happen next
and i think part two is starting up now
because we are in a queue for some sort
of
event
is anyone in let me know in the chat
actually if you're in you're probably
not watching the stream
but if you are and you're still hanging
out drop a line say uh what's going on
do we pog for donations uh no i don't
we don't have uh donations no donors
turned on on these streams appreciate it
though man thank you
um alex i am
male he says is that a guy or
oh you mean naga on the screen i was
like what the uh yeah naga is
a dude i think yeah he had a pretty
scruff voice in the trailer naga the
dude you're seeing
i think he's a guy it doesn't matter
still
badass i like that mask but i didn't
unlock it i didn't finish season
two's battle pass i was like 10 slots
away it was so annoying
and now we're probably gonna go into
season three after whatever happens
now whatever this is
new map is my mom's house all right
sick i'll give them a call make sure
they're okay
all right it has been how long have i
been here i would say like
six seven minutes the server queue on
the bottom
it's just like last time we might be
here for a little bit
uh but we eventually did get in so i'm
not worried just you gotta have a little
patience and thanks for
sticking around y'all
um if you are just joining us and you
wanna know
what happened in part one just let me
know
um i keep repeating it so i don't want
to bug everyone but
you know we just dropped in we finished
part one it's gone
fornance gets nuked some people are
still playing part one
okay cool good wait i don't know how it
should be over
uh probably okay the last games are
probably
ending what if the new map is cuba
that'd be cool is this fake andy garcia
asks
no it's real it's very real if uh
i wish i had something fake to play just
to show you guys instead of my face
let's play grit ball
the baby got nuked i'm hearing a lot of
that
kind of stuff i really hope nothing's
wrong with
the baby irl fetching
is that what people are saying they're
getting the fetching notification on
there
someone's in someone in the chat said
i'm in man all right
all right i'm just gonna put a quick
vocal poll
into the chat for you guys one i stay in
here
in this server queue for a little bit
longer two
i like back out and try again last time
it worked but it worked after 20 minutes
one stay to back out try again
let me know
what's up you guys for those of you just
joining yes
we're just waiting you know waiting for
part two
a lot of people are saying damn okay all
of you
99 of you are saying too okay
just gonna back out um see if that does
anything
try again right now i can't even back i
can't even
go back to the splash screen so i'm
gonna have to back out
all the way here we go
you know what might be smart too
look at that what is this
cancel and delete oh this is the one for
later okay i can't look at that
that's that's for later something's
going on later tomorrow
but for now let's try to get back into
the
part two event thank you for all the
twos thank you for that
for the let me know
it worked out really nice okay
here we are
checking for update fetching online
profile
trippy that's the second time you said
that i'm gonna double check and see if
everything is
okay with the baby because
keep saying r.i.p i don't like that
the baby fortnite
no there's nothing trending for the baby
you better quit playing i'll let
i'm just i'm on twitter checking news
for the baby and it's just memes of his
big head and the
let's go car
look it kicked me out okay let me try
that again
ah what
okay these showed up these showed up
here we go let's see i'm gonna i'm gonna
get ready to
hide the picture and picture of me here
just in case it opens on some sort of
cut scene but rebirth mini royale
duos we got some more options
people were saying rebirth i think this
is i think this is what's going on
friends
okay be right back
what the okay so confirmed rebirth
island at night
sorry i don't know why i'm thinking so
much okay here we are
it's happening you're done warming up
standby for deployment
to the war zone oh boy drop it into the
area what
you're still in the queue jordan you saw
it for yourself
restarting closing the game and
restarting it pushed me forward i think
let's go but i said duos i'm alone
yo my circles are f'd i cannot
post that comment here we go
wish me luck guys battle royale of
course i'm the squad leader
mark a drop point for your team i like
re
i like rebirth island but it's it's so
small and like
i can't like i don't do as well so i'm
gonna need all the support from
chat you guys your primary objective is
to kill em all
okay
nope i don't like c4 oh well there was
nothing else
this looks pretty cool at night yo i'm
getting pretty good haul here
this is fast i'll keep it
there we go here we go wish me luck you
guys rebirth island
night time part two oh they didn't
they're not calling this part too
what the hell am i doing um but
this is uh what's happening next oh
sheesh it's hot down there let me let me
calmly walk down the stairs
this was a good landing spot not gonna
lie no one was here to bug me
moving picking up anything else on the
way over
don't know why i i so calmly open that
door no one's around i should really
just be kicking everything
all right guys wish me luck oh they're
over they're so close and i'm
so low
[Music]
yeah i'm sorry for you guys who can't
get in uh restarting closing
the game and opening it back up helped
help me
i ain't got no fancy internet or
anything like that
i don't have a buddy i said duos and
they didn't pair me with anyone
no i don't want that gun
hmm frag yeah i don't like c4
i can't i'm no good at c4 that's a thing
c4 does not like me
all right well i wonder what's going to
happen we got the intro card saying
15 minutes this is taking place 15
minutes after
what happened in verdansk like we you
know
that's what it said [ __ ]
i was trying to just coast by
sorry i'm like
i shouldn't be a br streamer i feel bad
for
killing anyone i just want to see what's
going on
um see there's no timer there's no timer
outside of the regular smoke timer
so i'm wondering what will happen how
this will end
ah smoke i'm playing the smoke too fast
hmm i um
is that a self no just a stem okay i
will take this though
oh what is that oh just
lights for landing oh it's way too open
down here i gotta move i gotta move
apparently i have to search for
something chad is being so secretive
oh i hear a sniper i wish i had more
deadly silence
someone died uh oh
i'm not alone i'm not alone why are you
sorry
eric i know that's you
i got a friend request you know i don't
want to play with me
oh
uh eric i guess i'm sorry because i hate
being killed
in like br especially when it's like a
narrative thing like this like
trying to stick around to see what
happens but yeah i guess i can't be
sorry
i i wasn't sure earlier i think i saw a
zombie fly down you know those
that purple trail thing construction
construction site change that's right
this this rebirth map is supposed to be
a little different
they announced the command center also
there was one place that wasn't open
before
it should be open now that's what they
told us
oh
[Music]
someone's okay someone's been here it's
fine i gotta stay inside though
i don't i wish i had a teammate what's
happening yes i think it's about time i
should talk to you guys about for those
just joining
verdansk got nuked that was the nuke
event part one
there was an event where you ran around
fighting off zombies
the zombies took over verdance had to
get nuked there was no other option
and then part two which is what you're
watching now takes place
on rebirth island 15 minutes after the
nuke
dropped so there's no narrative
storytelling right now
just this it's ver it's it's it's
rebirth island at night
and like that's that's it right now
i killed one guy shout out to me
unemployment is fueling up oh no
get this done i'm not seeing zombies so
this is moving in
new safe zone located oh man he's right
there okay
what is part three live i don't even
know man i don't even know what's gonna
happen at the end of this
um so i wish i had i wish i had more
answers
you're just experiencing it live with me
right now
you guys play rebirth much i felt like i
liked it but i didn't really
enemy it came at a time when i was kind
of like
target is down well done nine targets
remain standing sort them out
how am i still alive
i need deadly silence i'm freaking out
guys
okay sunset
is that what you said
nothing but smoke i'm freaking out you
guys i'm freaking out
this is not this doesn't appear to be
zombie related so there's no respawning
if i die i die i think
and that freaks me out wish me luck
though
thank you for being here i hope you can
get in and play this yourself soon
i'm not sprinting so i don't make noise
by the way
objective is to eliminate the bounty
target
oh no
still not trying to run and make all
this damn noise i'm freaking out you
guys
by the way this is how i play battle
royale all the time so it's
i'm just normally constantly a mess
oh
is this part two i'm thinking so this
rebirth island at night
opened up with a title card that said uh
15 minutes after
you know the events of your dance or
whatever so i think this is narrative
for sure but
it's not giving any it's not giving me
any other details bouncy target is down
well done my bounty was killed
oh guys i don't know i got armor up
like talk about canopy game places brad
b i yeah
i'm nervous i'm a nervous br player so
i'm a little campy i'm not oh i see him
i'm not aggressive in fact i'm trying to
run away but there's nothing but hills
i'm toast you guys i'm toast
going for it
oh all i'm trying to do guys is see what
happens
when i win if i win is it a different
story
outcome i'm just trying to survive
oh can't figure stuff out if you're
dead exactly my guy see
but i mean honestly jokes aside this is
kind of how i play when i'm alone i
don't like playing
i try not to play solos this was
supposed to be duo's
six people alive can someone catch me up
nobody knows
give me one second i will i will catch
you up man i'm just
oh freaking out cause i'm a bad vr
player
you've got gas inbound safe zone
relocation okay
i think i'm in a good spot um nobody
knows this is for you
in chat verdance got nuked we played it
the limited time event that ended at two
o'clock part one
of this event was verdance getting nuked
apparently this is part two uh we're on
rebirth island at night
15 minutes after the nuke launched
so verdansk is vaporized my guys
oh sorry yes i am being campy
i want to win or at least you know have
a
gas is moving new safe zone located
that's my punishment guys
no okay hopefully we get to see what
happens
regardless
i tried oh no it's regular br no
nothing fun well let's see what happens
if i just leave
i don't know i think maybe there's no
narrative element
to this um
which is strange
not strange but oh i should have stuck
around
idiot no i don't think i don't think
they're gonna play like a trailer for
spectators you know what i'm saying oh
thank you
for the ggs you guys um so that's what's
going on right now it looks like
um these are verdants
all right now's a good time to catch up
thank you to those who are sticking
around and hearing me say this over and
over but to people who are just dropping
in at 12 o'clock today
pacific time uh the event started part
one
was verdansk it was overtaken by zombies
if you got killed you turned into a
zombie kind of like what's been going on
there was an x-fil zone but then uh the
x-fil zone
was compromised and then verdance got
nuked they showed a cut scene
that we may have up on gamespot's
youtube page right now
i think if we captured the gameplay it
got nuked
and then that event ended at two o'clock
you didn't really get anything except
for a calling card and you got to see
the nuke cinematic cutscene
then at two o'clock uh this started
happening they dropped in
rebirth at night
um so that's what's going on i try to
play a game and it is regular
um br like there's no zombies
it's regular br but it's at night at
night
you know what let's do resurgence quads
why is it white like this
me it's weird that it's like it's so
bright let me back
out take a sip of water here
yeah chad is saying we're not sure if
this is even part two
okay cool the cinematic cutscene is on
gamespot to youtube thank you
uh i don't wanna i don't wanna butcher
your name it's a beautiful long name
thank you the if you want to see
verdance get nuked
it's on our youtube page uh so let me
try this again
it's still like really blinding white
it's annoying um
let's see um rebirth king slayer mode
hmm i wonder if he can still do this
destruction of verdan's part it's still
part one
all right if nothing's changed which i
don't think it has in this section i'm
just gonna back out now this is just
part one
okay
that's strange can you guys not hear me
curtis does not like this event yeah i'm
gonna back out of this i don't think
anything's changed this is they're
letting people play this
still uh so i'm gonna back out of this
maybe do some resurgence for nighttime
rebirth island that's the new thing
right now that just launched
let's go quads i did duos and i made a
mistake
okay thank you guys you can hear me and
there's quite a delay i'm
i'm shocked
okay guys um so the map
uh i'm hearing from from our sources at
gamespot
that the map is up but i'm not sure if
uh
we will hear of an official part two
today see this is all we're getting this
is the only
tease
phelps in the chat he's been here almost
all morning he says i have to find out
get yourself have to find clues on
rebirth island as to what happened to
her dance i mean
i didn't really explore the map because
i'm freaking out and i'm a you know
sucker so i didn't go around exploring
very much
just you know it's night time and that's
the cool part and it
this takes place 15 minutes after her
dance got nuked and that's all they gave
us
so we'll play a few more rounds of this
and then um
we're gonna stream you know if something
comes up tomorrow we'll stream it for
sure
i may not be around myself or we know
we'll we'll figure it out as we go along
yeah i'm looking around i like it at
night enemy soldier ain't coming
but like you know is this is verdance
really gone it got nuked it got nuked
if you guys got theories in the chat as
to what's going to happen let me know or
what do you think the play by play is
going to be
because this just dropped and it's as it
i didn't play this map very much like i
should have
you dumb woman up stand by for
deployment to the war zone
oh no we're still getting in the chat
people are saying their servers are down
hey gameplay
all right finally i got some help you
guys saw how um
i did on my own i really i really like
help
although this is supposed to be quads
not three this keeps happening to me
battle royale look this dude already
pinged it
be advised gas is closing in proceed to
the site i'm this highbreaker huh
sheesh let's just go copy scavenger
control
wrong one oh it's so hot
okay watch out your primary objective is
to kill a mole
thank you that's not a door why can't it
guys i'm stuck look i'm stuck in this
little corner
hell pale no i'm stuck
man and you oh my god i'm stuck
can i i can't drop i can't go prone
look i'm running my character model is
running and i'm not touching anything
[Laughter]
oh you know what look at that i got
kicked it wasn't my fault
oh trailers um impulse games please
don't don't spam
um i didn't know this was being streamed
onto the gameplay channel
but shout out to you guys i'll open that
window and see if anyone's chatting
there
uh yeah but yeah please don't spam like
that i appreciate you being here
and i will i will check out gamespot
gameplay on
youtube so shout out to
everyone who's watching from everywhere
this is
this is cool game spot gameplay oh yeah
i got booted from that game
um and i was stuck servers are kinda are
goofing up
let's see let's try it again quads
yeah for those of you who were wondering
what i was talking about gamespot
gameplay
is a separate youtube channel we just
post gameplay usually with no
talking or or anything like that
editorialized it's usually just gameplay
so
we're live streaming this event on there
too apparently
so what's up to all those people
watching uh maybe not
i don't see it on here anyway
yeah thank you for all the f's
i thought it was me like i thought i
glitched my foot into the ground and i
just somehow screwed up but
i got kicked so it was it was the game
it wasn't me
all right guys either way one or you
know a few more matches of this and
we're going to call it
for the stream will be deployed
and this is this is what's happening
right now there's no
big story elements to rebirth island yet
it's more of an introduction i guess so
something may happen here
it's looking like uh tomorrow
but yeah we're dancing at night is new
hopefully i have a full team look at i'm
by myself
are people gonna join in like i got i
said
quads didn't i
there are nukes on rebirth hmm someone
says in the chat
let me look around people
hopefully people are just looking around
also and not trying to kill me what does
that say anyone speak russian
that might have been there before i
think this is area opened up it might be
new
i don't play rebirth very much so please
excuse me
yeah something something's cooking
and i'm not sure if it'll happen today
because we didn't get any cutscenes or
anything like that
all right that's enough [ __ ] about
now we do this for real let's see what's
up i'm gonna play a few more times and
we'll call it a wrap
oh no silly and it's okay i asked for
the f's it's all good
oh don't worry if you missed the nuke i
mean um it's
the video is up on our youtube page you
can check it out
happening we recorded the gameplay
approaching your position move to the
site
page why am i alone i thought this was
quads this is gonna happen again
enemy soldier incoming nova 6 factory
look at this there's stuff on the ground
someone said taking fire i'm toast
[Applause]
no where where's the door i'm toast i'm
toast
oh no that guy didn't see me why doesn't
he see me
this dude beat me up
hopefully
it's even harder to see that dark or in
the dark
eleventh how do i get 11. all right let
me play um
let me back out of this first of all and
try i think there was a resurgence mode
this is uh rough on your boy i uh
when i don't have reinforcements i'm a
good team player a good solo player i am
not
okay okay i picked rebirth resurgence
quads so i'm going to try that again
i want to see a full team of four
wreck boy the event okay
i think it's about time i talk about
what happened
um for those of you who are just joining
uh the event started today at 12 p.m
pacific time
and we played on verdansk and it was
overtaken by zombies
and then they give you a chance to
ex-fill the x-fil doesn't
work and zombies take over the entire
verdance map and it gets nuked
if you want to see that cut scene and
some of that gameplay we have it up on
our youtube page
now if you want to see verdance getting
nuked and then
after that this started to happen uh
rebirth island got a nighttime mode that
was
rolled out and it apparently it takes
place 15 minutes
get yourself sorted so we're looking for
intel we're looking to i mean i'm trying
to just stay alive honestly
um we're looking for intel apparently
some points of interest have changed on
rebirth island it is now
night time and some things have opened
up that weren't available before
uh but as far as another part two like a
part two to this whole
cinematic narrative
it's just it's just regular gameplay
when we were playing on for dance
earlier there was you know a cinematic
element
it ended with a with a cut scene of the
nuke it was really dramatic
but this is just back to regular
resurgence gameplay
uh so i'm not gonna play much more of
this i think you know uh you guys have
suffered enough
if my team does well then that's cool um
but right now it is uh
i think as far as the big ticket items
it might be over for today
all right that's enough [ __ ] about
now we do this for real
i can get on some people still can't get
on
battle royale yeah see there's no all
right soldier dramatic intro for this
team gas is closing on your position
suggest you get moving bounty contract
marked nope
let's go wish me luck friends
[Music]
oh right away eliminate all targets
okay all friendly all friendly
what is this look an easter egg
that was cool hopefully we can find more
of those
all right where's my team whoa
i was uh lucky
be advised there's an enemy team hunting
you
enemy soldier incoming more enemy
soldiers oh okay this is resurgence
i was like why are so many people
dropped but yeah so to sum up
this is this is what was launched after
verdance got nuked but
i think as far as you know big cinematic
things we might be done for the day
oh what up bros
nope too far too far
did he jump down i think so i thought
someone was on the water tower that's
why
you back up reload and think here
but yeah if you guys haven't if you guys
didn't get a chance to
watch the nuke event um we've got
gameplay up
on our our youtube channel the dance got
nuked
we have proof
evan in the chat says i'm gonna miss
verdansk
oh evian
i gotta reload this thing all right i
need a second here i need a second here
someone landed on the roof this mess is
hot here
don't want to steal kill don't want to
steal your kill
this dude almost landed right here in my
face yeah i need armor up
give me some peace for a moment
enemy soldier income
no this is battle royale
find some armor get that homeboy
okay so how many teams are left
nine teams 29 people
i'm gonna say we're not doing
you guys take care of them all armor up
no one's on the roof
someone's behind us too i'm convinced
it's because people keep uh a resurgence
game though that's what's going on here
i got arm up armor up my friends are
carrying me are here um
my teammates are definitely carrying me
i don't know four kills ain't bad all
right i'm gonna catch up with my homies
over here
good luck you guys i hope you're able to
get into this game mode
and hopefully i it looked like
the verdance mode from uh noon to two
o'clock was still playable
so check it out if you haven't already
my friends are so far wait up
enemy
oh boy
i almost
i don't want them to die they're good my
teammates that is
okay now time to calm down and reload
everything i have not been good about
reloading
yes more people in the chat are getting
in to the game
servers were bunky
we're being engaged move over here man
nice should have waited but whatever
got no plates you've got to shake it off
where is this mess you guys this map is
so small
okay friendly friendly good good 25
remaining nicely done
still alive somehow good news good news
why not
there's some armor wait
hostile drop it into the area what's
this guys
place is a maze it's modeled right after
alcatraz rebirth island is
mob of the dead christian hey
thank you for tuning in
here someone's like right underneath or
right above
nope enemy uav overhead all right
keep this ready actually i'll switch to
this this was good
the old stoner yeah someone's here get
ready
with your double soy [ __ ] pistols
gas is closing get to the new safe zone
this is a little too open so i'm going
to hang back with the homies over here
my station costs are adjusted it's a
trap
enemy cluster strike incoming take cover
okay good good yes
[Applause]
someone was like right below us now
they're gone wait i heard a blip
watch the skies
fire start prices are back to normal
okay someone dropped in but they didn't
land on our roof
where's our fourth guy
well we're all here okay
oh there's a load out like just outside
of our building i don't know if it's
worth it to risk
all right i'll go for it
yeah it is right outside our door it's
okay everyone's in the same spot it's
being camped
oh it's being camped hard on
oh no things are getting crazy i'm gonna
go back up
enemy uav forget it
enemy precision airstrike type man
where's everyone getting all these
airstrips
watch the skies no no back up
oh
every time i go up there's an enemy
somewhere else or every time i go down
there's an enemy
it's up to you now great my favorite
line
sensitivity goofed up
what is that i like the sound of that
well let's see here
no no no gulag and resurgence
we'll let this play out and i will catch
you guys up on what's going on for those
who are just
joined um verdansk there was a
the the limited time mode from 12 to 2
today where dance got nuked so we had to
try to exfil
if you got killed you turn into a zombie
and the x-ville mode or the x-fil plane
was compromised so
for dansk did get nuked if you want to
see that uh cinematic cutscene happen it
was
pretty dramatic it's on our youtube page
so check that out after that though
rebirth at night opened up and
apparently we're playing
15 minutes after the events uh with that
so that's what's going on for today and
i'm pretty sure that's all that's gonna
happen today
um but that's it as far as big like
storytelling
elements it might be more tomorrow i
think i think the schedule is like
out or something because chat was
talking about it
but um after we finish this up here
this will probably be my last game i did
want to just refresh it
on what's going um and people are still
trying to get in the servers have been
really hot today
unfortunately hey this guy's using my
fendic
underappreciated gun the fennec is so
we'll kick back and watch
well when this game ends i pretty sure
we'll just call the stream you should be
able to play this
um at least for the rest of the day
granted
or given if if the servers are
functional
it's night because of the nuclear
fallout i mean that's not a
bad guess but i don't forget i forget
how far rebirth is from
verdansk nine targets remain standing
sort them out
because there was a patch of sun like
amidst the clouds so that's a good guess
let's see here let's see how they do
this will be the last game i already
died
as you know
i can't believe this guy's using my
fennec
shouldn't be loading you making uh let's
see who else can i spectate
no i want to see this guy with an
iphonic
that's really nice thank you in the chat
let's see here
i don't want to butcher your name i
might have done that already but says
i just went 39 and one in arkhoff pete
today
to a crazy 94-51 and kill house to
peacefully
watching the stream in bed lovely call
of duty vibes thank you thank you
i had some trouble spitting that out but
thank you uh thank you for being here i
mean
i lost but i wanted to see if anything
happened what it looked like
when you do win in uh rebirth because
this is the new mode
and uh yeah um i can be a pretty heated
call
player some call of duty players
sometimes but hopefully you're here just
chill
vibes and while you're trying to get
into playing this yourself
as soon as i die we will end the stream
and we'll make some room so you can get
it
part two i don't think it's gonna be
today i'm assuming tomorrow they'll like
run this uh rebirth mode for a while and
then probably sometime tomorrow
the stream is entertaining doing better
thank you thank you so much i mean
it's i wish that were me playing but i
do enjoy reading the chat so
we can watch and chat together
but yeah i hope you guys were able to at
least play part one because part one was
the nuking the destruction of verdansk
four teams five people left let's go
let's spectate and see what's going on
that guy held it down for us we were in
fourth
thanks to that guy
oh i was playing with the clan they were
all g-a-w-g
they're all
well that's what happens you guys
nothing special
um but hopefully oh that's a cool skin
but hopefully um
soon thinking tomorrow that the event
might happen or like more of the
cinematic storytelling elements
but for now that's going to do it for
our stream let's let's finish this out
oh look at that it's done
we got fourth leave this game
all right you guys thank you so much for
watching everyone thanks it was kind of
a
crazy morning uh with a lot of waiting
so thank you for being here
once again if you do want to see the
part one of the nuking of verdansk that
gameplay is
up that cinematic cut scene where it
gets nuked is up
on youtube our gamespot youtube page uh
stick around the gamespot subscribe drop
likes all that stuff if you want to see
more of this stuff we want to keep
covering call of duty as best as we can
so stick around for more and we'll see
you next time
you